okay thank you
hope you all had a little break
and uh
it's quite uh an excellent talk that
john has given it's hard to follow him
but i will do my best okay so today i'll
try to tell you how to hide the secrets
in software
and my name is rachel
the fundamental question we are asking
here
is what is the minimum information that
a computer program that we work with
every day really needs to give away in
order to do its job
and when i say computer program you will
immediately think about some program
written in your favorite computer
language maybe python maybe java maybe
mala
but we know that theoretically all of
those can be translated into this
mathematical model called arithmetic
circuits in some finite field zp
and which basically involves a sequence
of addition and multiplication
in other words every output element is
the outcome of evaluating some
polynomial on the input variables
of course these polynomials are hugely
complex and they might have very very
high degree for example
the concept of program infestation in
cryptography its conception really dates
all the way back to the beginning of
public key cryptography
and here we're going one step further
and ask can we efficiently actually
transform some program that makes it
give away a lot of information into
another one that computes the same
function but now give away many more
information
it is really this compilation that we
are looking after and we call it a
fascinator and of course we're computer
scientists we want the fascinator to be
efficient and we wanted to produce and a
fascinated program that is not too much
slower than the original one as
efficient as the original one
program investigation has been a long
outstanding goal mainly for the purpose
of preventing reverse engineering
and there are a lot of ad-hoc
investigators out there
and in fact we humans also enjoy the
process of crafting pieces of software
that are hard to understand and there
are actually international contests for
this and here for example is a winning
entry a c code which looks rather
obscure
and can you guess what it is actually
when you run it it will start to display
some animated letters on the screen okay
unfortunately
all these ad hoc investigators one way
or the other tends to be broken by ad
hoc defescators
and in order to get out of this repair
and attack cycle that the cryptography
community wants to build a fascinator
that we can prove it's secure based on
really well-studied harness assumptions
which are basically conjectures that
certain computational problems such as
factoring the products of large primes
are
hard to solve efficiently
so before we can start to really think
about security in a mathematical manner
we need to first understand what is that
minimal information we're talking about
when that we are aiming for right
ideally and intuitively we really would
like the fastgate program to act like a
virtual black box
in the sense that the only information
that it gives away are the correct
outputs for chosen inputs
that would really be minimum because we
do want the first data program to
compute the same function meaning given
it anyone can choose some inputs they
like and evaluate and get the right
output
and i would also guarantee that all the
secrets in the program
that are not efficiently learnable by
looking at the input output behavior of
the program would now be really hidden
and this is really powerful okay one is
that
program investigation has been long
stored after in software industry for
protecting proprietary software so
consider a company who is concerned
about giving away its private machine
learning program to a cloud can now
first investigate it and stand the
vasculated version
now with it the cloud can
provide prediction service to clients on
behalf of the company and learn nothing
beyond the input output behavior
we can also use the program
infrastructure to hide data not just
software
by writing the data inside some of
fascist program
right the most naive way is to just hard
code a piece of data as a constant in a
program that will only output the data
when the right secret key is given as
the input
and therefore for adversaries who do not
know what the secret key is virtual
black box guarantees that the data is
really hidden
and this effectively implements
encryption
of course now we get talking that with
program investigation we can do new and
exciting things way beyond the scope of
basic encryption for example we can
enforce really fine-grained control
uh partial access to the data
so now let's think that here we have an
investor who like to delegate the job of
exchange in the stock market to a broker
but is concerned about giving away their
complete financial data
what they can do now is to first get
hide the data inside an investigative
program that will guard the data and
only answer certain very specific
queries when the matching credential is
present
with the fast kid program the broker can
now make limited query on the data that
is sufficient for him to make decisions
on the stock exchange but do not see the
data in its entirety
as we can imagine that program
investigation can in general enforce any
policy about who can compute what kind
of function on the data
when combined with encryption it can
also be used to achieve really advanced
cryptographic tools for example we can
enable a processor to compute all
encrypted inputs
here we can give it an investigative
program that has the right secret key
hardcoded inside the program when given
as input and encryption will internally
decrypt do the right processing and
finally re-encrypt the processed data
this way that we have effectively
implement one of the magical concepts
called fully homomorphic encryption in
crypto
but now again program investigation is
very flexible i can also give away part
of the process the data in the clear
without re-encryption
and now let's implement yet another
powerful tool called functional
encryption
and we can even think about combining
both of them together
so with all these great applications in
our mind it comes with great
disappointment that it turns out virtual
blackbox is impossible to achieve in
general
and this ultimately is because having
access to a program that computes the
function no matter how unintelligible it
is is more information than input output
behavior because for many programs it's
actually hard to learn the program
from just the input output behavior
so therefore ebv is a great goal except
that it's too good to be true
and therefore we look at a much more
realistic and humble goal called
indistinguishability investigation or io
for short
and it only guarantees the following
security property that if we started
with two programs that really compute
the same function for example these two
ways of evaluating the same polynomial
then we want their investigation to
become hard to tell apart
[Music]
in other words i only hide the
differences in different implementation
of the same function
this is indeed much weaker and now io is
possible
although on the flip side it is no
longer clear that whether it is really
powerful and useful
somewhat surprisingly that in all the
virtual black box applications
the crypto community has managed to
replace bbb with io including this
application for building fully
homomorphic encryption and functional
encryption
and furthermore that in the last
decade
io has really changed the cryptography
landscape so here is the cryptography
landscape before io with all these
magical primitives and objects that we
love
and they are built upon different kinds
of hard problems
and they leverage distinctive features
of each of those hard problems
so for example fully homophobic
encryption so far we only know how to
build them from lattices
on the other hand identity based
encryption we can build from a variety
of hard problems including factoring
lattices and computational different
helmets
if we have io
then
suddenly we can build almost all known
crypto goals
with without any other hard problem
anymore
in other words io can be viewed as
really a universal tool for
building cryptography
furthermore in the last few years it has
really taken us to a brave new world
where things that we didn't know how to
achieve before or didn't even try to
achieve before has now become true
can we build io then
[Music]
ever since the first candidate that was
proposed about 10 years ago in 2013 a
great celebrated work
the community has really poured into
huge efforts towards building io and the
dozens of construction have been
proposed using very different approaches
unfortunately up until recently all
these proposals rely one way or the
other on some kind of heuristic
in the form of newly conjectured harness
fortunately that all this amazing body
of work has really laid the ground and
forged the path for building io and in
two recent works that we managed to
finally obtain io from well-studied
assumptions
[Music]
and more formally that we build io based
on three hard problems i'll read them to
you
the first is the learning parity with
noise problem over large fields lpn
the second is the existence of a tool
called pseudorandom generator that has a
local structure
and the third we assume that certain
computational problems are hard on an
algebraic object called bilinear maps
with these three hard problems we can
construct i o
and for many of you maybe none of these
problems you have heard of or make any
sense but don't worry that i will
introduce some of them later when
they're needed
but i just want to note for now that all
these problems has had a history of
study and application cryptography and
they each has been studied in various
different areas with their roots in
information theory complexity theory
number theory and algebra
so
let me give you just
some taste some high level idea about
how we kind of fast get programs
really what we want is to have a way to
encode the description of a program
perhaps like encryption
however
we still want to be able to evaluate
arbitrary input x of our choice on the
program and obtain the output
towards this
we quickly realized that
in order to hide the program pi it is
not enough to just hide its description
in fact i must hide all the intermediate
computation steps because any
intermediate value may help us to
reverse engineer information about the
program pi
and this computation the challenges
really that we're dealing with arbitrary
programs enhance the computation of
evaluating input may be very very
complex and have a huge degree
and we must hide such a complex
computation
now this is rather daunting to tackle
with
right away
and the key idea is that we're trying to
transform this very complex computation
into another one
so that only a very simple
intermediate step of just degree 2 needs
to be hidden
and the rest of the computation can just
be done in the public securely
if we can really minimize the degree of
the secret computation to be such a
simple degree 2 polynomial then we know
how to hide it because we have this tool
called the bilinear map which
essentially allows us to compute degree
2 polynomials on secret values
and bilinear maps can be implemented
using elliptic curves which is a really
well-known mathematical tool that we use
day to day in order to secure internet
today
for most of you a curious mind you
probably are wondering what about the
degree three i mean what's special about
degree two what about degree three
interestingly until now we still don't
know a direct algebraic way that can
allow us to securely compute degrees
three polynomials and degree two is what
we know
okay so how can we now transform a very
complex computation into one where only
some very simple intermediate step needs
to be hidden
towards this our first action is
actually going to transform this
evaluation for the input x
into two steps that we call height and
decode
in those two steps only the first step
height actually depends on the input x
to be evaluated
and it will produce an intermediate
outcome o
and from which we can apply a decoding
procedure in the public to obtain the
output
okay so for security really hold
let's get thinking is that i really want
this intermediate outcome all to contain
only information about the outcome y and
nothing else about the program pi
right if that's the case then indeed the
decoding can be done in the public
because all the intermediate value also
would only depend on the output y
and so we can think about the height
procedure as some kind of special
encryption that really only allows
revealing the output for a single
specific income for single single
specific input and hide all other
information about the program
it turns out that this can actually be
done using quite classical cryptography
tools such as double circuit and
randomized polynomials
and this is a great step
and now
if we look closely into the height
procedure
we see that really the most crucial step
inside it is evaluating a pseudo-random
generator
what is the pseudo random generator it's
one of the most basic and fascinating
tool in cryptography which allows us to
expand a very short truly random bit
stream which we call a seed into a much
longer output that looks random okay we
really want the output to be much longer
than the input for example
the input is
square root of the length of the output
and here by random looking what we mean
is that the output r which we know is
not truly random it doesn't have enough
entropy however it is computationally
hard to tell with the part from a truly
random string of the same lens and hence
called the pseudo-random
so in cryptography we can build
pseudo-random generators from all sorts
of hard problems
but we have also wondered for a long
time that how simple can such
pseudo-random generators be
in other words what kind of simple
functions can already produce random
looking outputs
and here for the purpose of program
investigation we don't want just
ordinary simple we one extremely simple
we want a prg that is computable by just
degree two polynomials
can we have it
with extensive effort unfortunately
up to now
all the proposals that have been
attacked and we don't know whether we
can have
uh degree two pseudorandom generators
so the simplest prg that we do have have
this local structure which means that
every output bit depends on just a few a
constant number
of input bits however that number must
be at least five
and this structure
immediately implies that such prgs can
be computed using low degree polynomials
however again the degree is at least
five
so we're kind of stuck right i don't
actually know how to securely compute a
degree five polynomial the only thing i
have is a bilinear map that can only
compute degree 2.
on the other hand that we don't have
degree 2 to the random generators
so the final piece of idea is that
perhaps we can just work in between and
have what we call quoting quote degree
2.5 prgs
well this doesn't really make any sense
so let me explain
here we're going to split the input to
the prg the seed into a public and the
sacred part the public card called the
public seed p and the sacred part called
the secret seed s
again i want the total length of the
public and sacred seed to be much
shorter than the length of output so i
gained something
so with this kind of structure
and what do i mean what do i really mean
by the public see being public i mean
that the
r should still be hard to distinguish
from truly random even when adversaries
are given the public seat that's what it
means that it is public
now with the two-part input
we can think about the slightly more
complex prgs
which
really has degree two in the secrecy
and hence it can always be written as a
sum of quadratic monomials in the
secrecy
but now the coefficients of those
quadratic monomials can depend on the
public seed and its dependency can be
more complex
of some constant degree that is at least
five
this is what we mean by degree 2.5 prg
that it sort of is sitting in between
degree 2 prg and degree 3 prg
and not too hard to imagine that this
kind of structure we can still securely
compute using by linear map because
after all the computation that depends
on sacred information the secret seed
here is really degree two
the final piece of the puzzle is whether
i can have those kinds of degree 2.5 prg
and this is answered affirmatively in
the two recent works where we showed
that there is actual way to generically
transform a local prg which we do have
into a degree 2.5 prg using this last
assumption which is the learning parity
with noise in finite field
and in summary that approach that we
take towards building program
investigation is really to gradually
transform a highly complex computation
step by step into one where the part of
the computation that needs to be done
hidden have lower and the lower degree
until all the way down to degree two
note that in all those transformations i
did not really reduce the complexity of
the computation
or the computation is still as complex
as the original program which is
necessary the only thing that has become
smaller and smaller degree is which part
i need to actually hide
and i want to just
mention that in this whole journey
towards building i o that
simon's institute have really been a
pushing force for the community through
multiple programs and workshops
in fact my personal journey towards
building program infestation really
started here in the cymos program in the
cryptography program in 2015
and
with the program that is running now
that we have the opportunity and the
platform to really look forward to what
we can further do with program
investigation
and
while we celebrate that we now know that
io is feasible based on well-studied
assumptions i want to say that we really
first just at the beginning of the road
towards understanding it
we still need a major paradigm shifts
new ideas so that we can build io in
efficient and practical manner and we
still need time to really think and
reflect about what program investigation
can bring us in the future
for example
whenever i say the word secrets what do
you think of
i think about the locked doors
close the safe classify the documents
very very secure encryption
all these ways that keep secrets secure
and safe but also useless right i can no
longer compute on these secrets i can no
longer learn useful information from
them
however program investigation offers a
different way
a way that we can create useful secrets
by hiding them inside the vascular
program which still allows us to compute
on them but now only those permissible
use
and this really depicts to me a
fascinating feature that how we can use
secrets and private data in the future
and this concludes my talk thank you
[Applause]
questions
yes thank you for the great talk i was
just curious what the
uh assumed hardness
that sub-exponential of these problems
was yeah so what it means is that
um
for each of the hard problems when we
talk about computational assumption we
can talk about first what is the
computational problem we're thinking
about and now we can think about what is
the strength of the harness we want and
typically you can the weakest is to
assume that
the problem is hard to solve
by polynomial time adversaries
and the other problems are problems that
are hard to solve for even
sub-exponential time adversaries however
a little bit of fine print the
sub-exponential harness i mean here is
not that what i mean here is that it is
hard for polynomial time algorithms to
solve those problems with the
probability that is bigger than some
sub-exponential amount
that make sense
okay cool
[Applause]
thank you
now